despair that accompanied the retirement
of andrew luck in late august was
followed by early season euphoria in
indy five and two were the indianapolis
colts a lot of praise for jacoby
brissette and then something happened
and it very well may be mcl injury
against the steelers never quite the
same after that but there is a clear
sense of ambivalence chris sims toward
jacoby brissette now darius leonard the
great linebacker for the colts recently
spoke out on brissett's behalf saying he
doesn't get enough respect well he
should take that up with jim irsay the
owner of the team or others in the
organization who are making it clear
that they are looking elsewhere to
upgrade at the position and i don't
think anyone believes they shouldn't
other than darius leonard well yeah i
mean listen you know again this goes
back to you know what we're even hearing
with the 49ers players and jimmy
garoppolo and all that of course hey
yeah the guys in the locker room at that
time are going to support the guy in the
locker room i mean that's who they know
they have a personal relationship so i
would expect a player in indianapolis to
say that but yeah the facts of the
matter are you know i don't agree with
darius leonard you know i i you could
you could argue that before the knee
injury i mean before the knee injury i i
said he was a top 10 quarterback in the
league at that point i was like man he's
he's right there around the top ten he's
playing great was great in some big
clutch moments was making some great
plays but he meant after the knee injury
it just fell apart and it's not even
like not necessarily all just the it was
mental it was physical it was everything
and i like i told you earlier in the
week mike i was told by somebody that i
really trust
uh in the business that just said
there's no way jacoby percept will not
be the starting quarterback with the
indianapolis colts next year he might be
on their roster but they are going to
look to get somebody else in there to be
the guy in indianapolis
yeah and i think how much is paid
to the next guy is going to show whether
or not brisette's got a chance to
compete
or whether he's even got a chance to
stick around i mean he's a guy who gets
unloaded he's got a guaranteed roster
bonus north of 8 million almost 9
million
salary of 6 million in change on top of
it they may be stuck with him unless
they can trade him somewhere but you
know if it's a nick falls we talked
yesterday about the possibility of falls
being traded to indy falls is around 15
16 million in compensation you could
keep both guys in theory yeah but if
they go out and make a play for somebody
at 25 million or more i think that tells
you number one that guy's clearly the
starter and number two brissette's got
to worry about getting shipped out of
town altogether yeah i think you're
right i think if you get if they get
somebody with an andy dalton
nick foles type contract then jacobi
percent i do think has a good chance to
what you're saying to be on the roster
and be that backup quarterback which you
know i think is probably where the colts
think he is right now they probably
think he's a really high-end backup
quarterback but if it's like philip
rivers which we've heard that
conversation a lot as well right if he
comes in and then signs you know to what
you're saying a 25 28 million dollar
contract yeah he's going to be the guy
and then i would think jacoby brissett
will be on the trade block and who the
hell knows maybe he ends up back in new
england too i mean you know we certainly
know there's going to be teams that are
either looking for a bridge quarterback
or even looking for a high-end backup
quarterback in case you know their their
other quarterback they have that they
have an issue with right now can you
know he can come in and play there he
could be a backup to tie rod tailor with
the chargers he could do any of that so
uh there's so many moving parts here
with this this conversation
and think about the phases of
quarterback free agency this year we're
gonna have phase one yeah where the land
rush happens for the big names then
we're gonna have phase two the guys who
are left over after the big money is
spent and the guys who are supplanted
by the fact that their team has gone out
and found a new quarterback like jacob
bessette will be then we've got that
period after everything kind of slows
down entirely and teams are awaiting the
draft that's when they make contingency
plans for guys they will pursue
if they don't get who they want during
the draft and we've seen trades happen
after a round one if there's a guy you
want in round one and you don't get him
what do you do the next morning you make
a trade for a guy whether it's a
quarterback or some other position so
there's going to be a lot of different
moving parts here and it's going to
start the 18th of march and it's going
to continue into may chris and maybe
beyond because you know there's so many
quarterbacks now this is a topic for
another segment yeah another day right
at some point the league can justifiably
talk about expanding because it's not as
dire as it was just a few years ago
there's a lot of quarterbacks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports